In this problem, a municipal utility
treats groundwater to reduce hardness
using an ion exchange softener. The
untreated water characteristics were
recorded during testing and are in the
provided table. The softener reduces
hardness effectively, but still allows a
leakage hardness of 10 mg per liter as
CA3
in the treated stream. To maintain
corrosion control while also preserving
taste, the utility blends some untreated
groundwater with the softened water to
produce a finished water hardness of 90
mg per liter at CA3.
What percentage of untreated groundwater
should be bypassed and blended with the
softened water to achieve the desired
finished water quality? The possible
percentages are 24%, 27%,
30%, and 33%.
So in this problem, the ultimate goal is
to figure out what percentage of the
groundwater can be bypassed during the
ion exchange softener. That means that
the first thing we have to do is figure
out which of the parameters contribute
to hardness in the problem.
Hardness in water is caused mainly by
two ions, calcium and magnesium.
These are naturally present in ground
water and surface water and they're the
reason for that chalky buildup on
faucets or the need for extra soap. So
in this problem, we are going to be
pulling out the values for calcium and
magnesium.
For step two of the problem, we are
going to convert calcium and magnesium
from milligs per liter into mill
equivalents per liter.
This standardizes the concentrations
based on each ion's charge and molecular
weight.
So to find the miller equivalents per
liter, we have the concentration, but we
need to go into the reference manual and
find the equivalent weight for each
parameter. In version 1.6 of the
environmental reference manual, page 22
contains a table called common radicals
in water. This is one place in the
manual from which you can obtain these
numbers. So the equivalent weight of
calcium is going to be 20 and the
equivalent weight of magnesium is going
to be about 12.2.
So to convert calcium we will divide our
concentration of 72 mg per liter by the
equivalent weight of 20
to get 3.6 mill equivalents per liter.
Then
we can divide the concentration for
magnesium of 18 mg per liter by its
equivalent weight of 12.2
and get just about 1.5 mill equivalents
per liter.
The total hardness in this problem will
be the sum of these two values
totaling 5.1 mil equivalents per liter.
Now that we are halfway through our
conversion in step three, we can convert
from mill equivalents per liter
to mg per liter as Ca3.
[Music]
In many water softening problems,
hardness is reported as milligrams per
liter as calcium carbonate or CO3
because it provides a consistent basis
for comparison among many parameters. To
do this, we can multiply the total
miller equivalent per liter by Ca3's
equivalent weight of 50, also found in
the reference manual. 5.1 mill
equivalents per liter time 50 gives us
just about 255
mg per liter as Ca3.
That's going to be the raw water
hardness.
Finally, we can apply the bypass
fraction formula here
to determine the percentage of water
that needs to be bypassed in order to
achieve the given finished water
hardness.
[Music]
The equation for bypass hardness is
going to be the finished hardness minus
the leakage hardness
over the raw hardness minus the leakage
hardness.
[Music]
The problem statement itself gives us
the finished hardness of 90 mg per liter
as Ca3
and the leakage hardness
of 10 mg per liter as Ca3.
On the bottom of the equation, we've
calculated the raw hardness to be 253
mg per liter SCA3.
And again, our leakage is going to be 10
We can ignore these units since they are
all the same. And finally, we can see
that our answer is 33%. Or the fourth
answer below.
So the big points to this problem are
understanding
which parameters you need when thinking
about hardness,
converting those to mill equivalents per
liter and summing them together, and
then converting again to millig per
liter as Ca3 so that they match the
units of the rest of the values in the
problem. And then finally using the
bypass hardness equation to calculate
the percent that should be bypassed. And
that's it.